[MUSIC]
The silence felt like it stretched to
infinity, and my faith was beet red,
frozen like a deer in headlights,
I stammered for words.
Finally I heard the voice of my general
partner coming and swooping to save me,
like a remote and distant loudspeaker
from some far off planet,
bringing me back to the present, to sand
hell road conference room to the perfect
square of California
sunshine in front of me.
Mina is not an executive assistant.
She is an associate partner at this firm.
A huge wave of relief washed over me and
I let out the breath I didn't
even realize I had been holding.
I tell you guys a story because it is
literally one of the most cringe worthy
moments of my entire life.
But also it because it is the moment,
that I felt like an absolute
outsider in venture capital.
I felt like an outsider because I was a 22
year old female in this old boys club of
venture capital.
And the truth was,
I probably was never going to fit in.
Today, only 16% of venture
capital investors are women.
And only 3% of all of venture capital
in America goes to female CEO's.
This is crazy to me.
My experiences as a recovering venture
capitalist and now as the founder of
my own Y Combinator back startup are just
incredibly difficult for me to talk about.
Because I have gone through all of
the stages of grief about how capital is
allocated in our country.
Denial, anger, just so
much anger and rage.
How is it that this group of just
incredibly well meaning people who are my
friends, who are my mentors could
yield systematically unequal outcomes.
How is it that an industry that is
considered by most to be the most
meritocratic in the world, has portfolio
that look the way that they do?
And finally, I circled back to optimism,
optimism because all of the amazing
female founders that I've met here
at Stanford, and all of the amazing
female investors I know are going to go
on to change things in venture capital.
I'm here to help you skip all of those
stages of grief that I went through and
jumped to that optimism part as well.
I want to start by just talking about some
of the biggest reasons I think exists for
this persistent gap in funding.
The first, is the pipeline problem or
probably not in the way that you think?
Yes, women only get 20% of the computer
science degrees in this country.
But the real problem is
that we are using that as
a pipeline to figure out who gets funded.
This outdated investment criteria
that technical chops are somehow
a prerequisite for
being a startup CEO is absolute bullshit.
We need to get rid of these archetypes
we have in our head of what
an ideal startup founder looks like.
Having moved to the operator side now,
I can tell you there is an enormous
laundry list of things that you
need to be and a great CEO.
Nowhere on that list is knowing how
to write a single line of code.
And we need to make sure that women
are not opting themselves out because they
don't check off all of these boxes.
The second, which I know all too well,
is the lack of diversity in
the decision makers in this country.
It's funny how the people that you happen
to trust just look a hell
of a lot like you.
And all of those original
early stage venture capital
decisions are built on trust.
One thing I learned in venture capital is
that sourcing is often playing basketball
with your Harvard fraternity brothers.
The people that you trust just happen
to look a hell of a lot like you.
Maybe they went to
the same schools as you.
Maybe they were in the same fraternity.
You have to check those types of things.
The last is unconscious bias.
In an HBS study published in 2017,
researchers found that when
women walk in for a pitch, they are way
more likely to get questions that
are about the potential risks of
the business versus the potential gains,
even when giving identical
pitches as a male CEO.
As a result, even when women
are given the opportunity to pitch,
they often are overlooked.
This is equivalent to asking one
set of Yelp reviewers in what way,
was your food Michelin star and asked
me a different set of Yelp reviewers.
In what way did your
servers screw up your meal?
The real world is obviously
a lot more subtle than that.
But all of us have these unconscious bias
sees that impact the way that we make
decisions in this world.
I wanted to take a moment to just reflect
on, Why this matters so much in the world.
Venture capital is a tiny industry,
but it is an important gatekeeper
to the types of ideas that end
up existing in this world.
What kind of amazing ideas are we missing
out on because the group of people
we are backing come from such
a small homogenous and elite group.
Second, equity returns are a huge driver
of wealth creation in this country.
50% of all fortune five companies
originally VC or Angel Bact.
So if you look at all of those inequities,
all of the systematic wealth
inequities in this country, a lot of
those originate at an earlier stage
than you would think, at how capital
is allocated In the beginning, and
to whom capital gains accrue both
on the founder and funder side.
What I said today for women holds true for
so many other groups as well.
These marginalized communities
are also in need of allies Lastly,
y'all are just missing out on
some crazy outsized returns.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Companies
founded by women are faster
to reach profitability.
They're more capital efficient,
they literally returned twice
as much per capital invested.
As with most asset classes it
pays to invest in the underdog.
This past year marked a record in
flow of capital into renter capital.
And yet, over that same time period,
the percentage of women
getting allocated that
capital actually decreased.
It pisses me off in so
many ways to see the numbers slide
backwards from 3% to something
even lower [LAUGH] than 3%.
Yet there's also so
much to be optimistic about.
Last year also marked one of the biggest
IPOs ever by a female founder and
Stitch Fix.
And one of the largest funding rounds ever
in women's health, which is just been
an area that has been so systematically
under invested in for generations.
We still have so
far to go to get to 50% but
we have so much to be proud of and
to celebrate as well.
I am tired and sick of waiting on
the sidelines for the numbers to change.
I am in a room of movers and shakers.
And I know that if we commit to this,
we can change it.
I'd love to re center again on
the things that really matter and
the things that we can do.
To the women in this room,
for our founders,
you inspire me to be
a better version of myself.
Thank you and I'm with you.
I will be your hype woman for life.
To the women who are considering
entrepreneurship but holding themselves
back for whatever reason, I believe
in you and you should own that space.
To the Allies in the room?
We need you to believe in us,
to mentor us to invest in us.
And lastly, to the investors in the room.
Change the face of your industry,
it is not enough to just hire
a token female junior team member.
It is exhausting to be [LAUGH]
the token junior female team member.
The solution is to hire at least two.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
recognize that you will
need to mentor them.
They will face just immeasurable
uphill challenges as torchbearers
in the industry of venture capital.
And lastly, I find it fun people who
don't look like you, because it literally
makes financial sense to do so but
also because it is the right thing to do.
I know that the next Mark Zuckerberg
will not look like him.
That founder is probably in this room.
Go be her go work for her or go fund her,
because I know she will
return your entire fund.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]